Transcriptor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Quisiera compartir una reflexión
sobre lo que puede significar
una cultura colectivista
en un momento como este en el que
el mundo está viviendo una pandemia.
Yo no soy médica.
Mi mamá es japonesa.
Y, además, en mi trabajo de muchos años
he tenido contacto
con cuestiones literarias,
sociológicas y antropológicas
de la cultura japonesa.
Y creo que ciertos comportamientos
y respuestas, sociales e individuales,
de la sociedad japonesa
pueden servirnos a la hora
de afrontar una crisis como esta.
Vale hacernos una primera pregunta.
¿Por qué Japón pudo evitar
mayor impacto del contagio
si ya en enero se dio el primer caso?
Estando tan cerca de China,
teniendo casi 130 millones de habitantes
en muy reducido espacio,
teniendo de las poblaciones de
tercera edad mayores del mundo,
siendo el segundo país con más fumadores
por cantidad de habitantes,
¿por qué en Japón
la infección de este virus
no ha tenido un crecimiento exponencial,
sino un avance lineal y lentificado
hasta ahora?
Sabemos que este nuevo coronavirus
es muy contagioso.
En estos datos demográficos
entonces Japón nos presenta un cóctel
que permitiría una gran propagación
de la enfermedad.
Básicamente, muchísima gente en poco lugar
y un cuarto de esa gente con más de 65.
¿Qué pasa entonces?
La japonesa es una sociedad educada
de tal manera
que responde de forma orgánica y unida
ante cualquier evento que la comprometa.
Japón pasó por guerras, tifones, tsunamis.
Japón recibe 1500 terremotos por año;
mil temblores por día.
Generación tras generación ha tenido
que sobrellevar catástrofes,
naturales o generadas por el hombre.
Esto lo podemos pensar con algo que
les gusta mucho a los argentinos:
equipos de fútbol, como ejemplo.
¿Qué equipo de fútbol
va a tener mejor performance
ante un momento crítico?
¿El equipo que entrena todos los días,
tiene infraestructura,
en el que cada uno sabe
qué tiene que hacer?
¿O el equipo que nunca entrenó,
que no tiene infraestructura,
y que tiene que salir a improvisar?
Las directivas de distanciamiento social,
higiene y comportamiento individual,
sea en sociedad o en la casa propia,
la población japonesa las tiene
establecidas desde hace cientos de años.
No hace falta decir
"No abrazarse", "No darse besos"
porque no lo hacen.
Se saluda con una reverencia.
Dar distancia es un gesto de respeto.
Y la mayoría de los trabajadores
en lugares públicos usan guantes.
No hace falta recomendar
sacarse los zapatos al entrar a la casa
porque ya es costumbre.
No hay que indicar no estornudar
ni toser sobre otra persona
porque esto es un protocolo habitual
entre los japoneses.
De hecho, estudios de hace años
muestran que más del 50 % de japoneses
usarán barbijo al sentirse resfriados
no para proteger a sí mismo
sino para proteger al otro.
Aquí va el mensaje fundamental
de una cultura colectivista.
El bien del todo es más importante
que el bien de una parte.
Para ilustrar esto me gustaría cerrar
con una experiencia
que hicieron dos maestros occidentales
en un colegio en Japón.
Seguramente conocerán
el juego de las sillas.
Se pone música, sillas en un círculo,
una menos que la
cantidad de participantes,
y se van sacando de a una en cada ronda.
Se hizo esta experiencia en Japón.
Y los chicos, en vez de empujarse
para tomar una silla,
quedaron todos cediendo el lugar
a un compañero.
Porque da vergüenza ganar uno
cuando otro sufre.
La palabra japonesa "amae"
expresa esta manera de ser.
Se trata de tener la confianza
de que el otro me va a cuidar.
En resonancia con sentir que
nos realizamos cuando cuidamos de otros.
En el ejemplo hay niños,
pero ya podemos ver cómo funciona
una sociedad colectivista.
Se ayuda a sí misma,
porque cada individuo
contribuye al bien de todos.